well hello it's time for a very special
summer edition of
cruise news
if there was an olympic event for feel
good news
we'd be going for the gold every time
joining me today
is someone who is no stranger to gold
medals
three-time gold medal winning gymnast
and
a personal hero ally raisman
[Applause]
i'm so excited me too i'm such a big fan
i've like done such a deep dive into
your life over the years and i'm just
always mesmerized by
everything that i learn about you and
funny enough
which wasn't funny at all i was reading
that your dog went missing
and i freaked out on the 4th of july
what happened and is there a happy
ending to this story
yes so milo's right here sleeping with
me he's he's safe and he can
um help so it was just really bad timing
and really bad luck i just was taking
milo out for a very quick walk
saturday on july 3rd it was like a five
minute walk i wasn't even
two feet from the door to get into my
building and the fireworks just started
going off i live in the city
i didn't take my lettuce to the
fireworks but because i'm in the city
they're just so loud so even if they're
like far away they're still very loud
for the dogs but unfortunately the
fireworks that went off are very close
to us so
i had milo on a leash and a harness and
he
i had the leash in my hand and he just
panicked and
bolted and i tried to grab him but i
just couldn't and
it took me six days to get him back it
was i'm still a little traumatized not a
little very traumatized from the
experience
because he is my everything i i mean he
sleeps in my bed
every single day i i love him
so so so much and he's helped me through
so many hard times
and those six days felt like an eternity
but i'm just so grateful and the people
who found him
are amazing i've gotten coffee with them
i feel connected with them and i'm just
it was a happy ending for me and i'm
very grateful he's okay
well you're such an amazing advocate for
you know obviously canines and humans
does it spark a fire in you to get
involved in something
definitely just how many people and
animals are affected by fireworks it
really makes me think about things
differently and just wanting to
use my platform in a way that maybe
helps spread the word that people
shouldn't just be randomly putting off
fireworks because it has a really
um dramatic effect on a lot of living
things in the world
i've only had milo since the end of
october but i mean he's helped me
become more secure in who i am he's just
been such a big part of my healing
journey that
i just was so crushed and devastated
last week and i'm just so grateful that
um
he's here with me now he's okay oh this
is a happy ending okay good this makes
me so happy
um well ali um i would be uh
a bit nutty not to speak to you about
the
olympics they're about to kick off um in
japan and are you ready we want to talk
sports sports sports yes
all right the 2020 olympics are finally
happening
kids are going back to school the
olympics are happening people are
traveling
it's you know step by step we need to be
cautious and careful which actually
uh really pertains to the story and some
of the questions i have you know the
ceremonies are kicking off july 23rd
and there's going to be 229 different
events
and 33 sports
including four new ones ali will you
take us through what the four new sports
are
yes so they're surfing and climbing
which is super cool
and there's also skateboarding too i
took skateboarding lessons a couple
weeks ago
and wasn't very good at it have a lot of
respect for
skateboarders it's really scary and it's
really hard to get the balance
but it was fun i mean if you have a hard
time skateboarding there is zero hope
for a lot of us if you're like it's
really hard to balance i'm like
how how is this possible i mean your
missus balance i think it's funny
because
you know i did gymnastics for since i
was two years old and i ate i stopped
every other sport just to do gymnastics
and i think people are surprised that
how bad i am when i try other sports
because it's all i've ever known
i'm not very good at it but i want to
keep trying it i love
that spirit that you just keep trying if
i tried bmxing i feel like i'd show up
at a hospital with half the bike inside
of me
um i wouldn't want to try it either it
sounds terrifying
i um the tokyo olympics are going to
look
a lot different this year because of
kovid
and it's crushing to me because that
support
of your family the crowds cheering the
fans you made
such a mark on the world with you and
your family the way they supported you
is so iconic to your story
i mean what do you have to say to people
about how it will be different uh
the pluses and minuses of it being the
way it is
yeah you know we obviously are in a
pandemic
and um safety always has to has to be
the priority for everyone and this is
unprecedented times you know and if
they've concluded that spectators
should be excluded because of safety
concerns then that's what needs to be
done
but i also think as you said it's
important to acknowledge that
you know i was very fortunate that my
parents were able to go to both of my
olympic games and having their support
meant
everything to me i'm sure the athletes
and families or their loved ones or
friends that wanted to go watch they're
they're disappointed and they're bummed
one of my favorite things of the
olympics is actually um
pin trading and getting to meet athletes
from all over the world and
whether they're athletes or even
spectators of trading pins and so
it's definitely going to look a lot
different but we're also in a very
different time
so i think that acknowledging both sides
of it is really important
do you think the athletes feed off the
crowd
and what's it going to be like with
silence i think it totally depends you
know for me personally when i was
training
for both olympics a lot of the time i
was just by myself in the gym with my
two coaches so to be honest i kind of
got used to it being really quiet
sometimes in gymnastics when you're
competing for example in a beam final
it's actually so quiet in there and you
can literally hear
a pin drop oh it is on this set too
sometimes
and then somebody from the home country
goes on floor and the crowd erupts like
that's the beauty of the olympics is
that it brings
the whole entire world together and i
think that
everything that our world has been
through in the last couple of years i'm
i'm really excited for the opportunity
hopefully to bring the world together
and to celebrate amazing athletes who
are working
so hard and i'm excited to even check
out the new sports i think surfing is so
cool i've never done it before but i'm
excited to watch it
well i'm sure you could shred um now
may i ask you know you're the captain of
the team
you know for several olympics and
you you know now you're not doing a
gymnastics anymore like when you and the
girls are sitting around
and the first half of your life is so
focused
is so laser sharp so the
extraordinary example of what human
capacity
is and can reach what do you talk about
with like
second chapters and then what you'll do
like after
you know i've i've gotten asked that a
lot from a lot of different athletes in
other sports because i think it's such a
normal thing
to struggle with what you want to do
when you're done with your sport or who
you are outside of the sport i think
it's so relatable
to college athletes or even someone
who's not a collegiate athlete but they
have this amazing college experience and
they don't know what they want to do for
a career
path so i kind of got to a point where i
started working on myself a lot and i
started to think about the way that i
talk to myself really matters my inner
dialogue is so important and really
shapes
how i feel every single day and i
thought about it and
if a friend or another athlete came to
me for advice i would tell them
it's okay to feel that way take the time
that you need figure out who you are
figure out what you like to do outside
of the sport figure out what makes you
happy and figure out like what about the
sport
gives you this like passion and fire and
this drive and find that and other
things in life because you can find that
in other things
and then i started to realize if i'm
saying that to myself to
a friend i need to be saying that to
myself and i started doing that
and i realized like the anxiety about
not doing gymnastics anymore
really like started to go away and of
course watching the olympics i'm sure
i'm gonna for that moment be like oh i
wish i was out there i wish i could be
celebrating with them that's again i
think that's normal i'm sure so many
athletes decades after they're done
competing kind of wish that they could
be back out there
but i realized that if i really focus on
myself if i'm kind of myself
and i treat myself the way i would treat
a friend um the process of figuring out
who i am outside of gymnastics is going
to be a lot more enjoyable
and a lot more fun so and i also think
without realizing it i kind of was
i got put into this role of um
being an advocate for other survivors of
sexual abuse and i never
imagined it to be like that but i think
it gave me such a deeper purpose
outside of gymnastics and it helped me
have this confidence that
i am more than a gymnast and there is so
many amazing things that i can do
in life and i'm still working on like if
i took away the olympic medals the
gymnast
being a survivor all of those things and
took away even
me being in the public eye who would i
be like who
am i on a saturday morning when i'm
taking milo out for a walk what do i
like to do
and so those are the things i'm working
on now and it's really been awesome
i am so glad that i asked you that
question
because i do appreciate everything that
you've done
in raising awareness i as a parent
you know watching what you went through
i just we need people like you the way
you put yourself out there
makes me feel like we have a chance at
protecting our daughters
and our sons and i'm just in
awe of everything you've accomplished in
your life
both for yourself and for other people
you really are my hero thank you
good luck to all the athletes that are
competing at the olympics this year we
will be watching you and cheering you on
ally please i'd love to talk to you
again about so many things
thank you so much thank you so much for
having me thank you
you